[موسيقى]
اولا انا مش قادر اقوللكم انا مبسوطه ان
انا موجود معاكم في اسم كبير زي اسم تدكس
طبعا انا ما كنتش اعرف عنهم حاجه بس كتر
خيرهم يعني عملو لي قيمه كده وقالو لي
تعال تكون معانا النهارده
يعني انا خريج تجاره خارجيه 95 في اشتغلت
على طول الحمد لله بعد ما اتخرجت في سنه
96 كنت بشتغل في شركه مقاولات في الزمالك
فانتم عارفين شركات مقاولات بيبقى واخده
زي شقه في عماره كده
فكان باب الشركه باب ازاز الومتال كده
فجيت في يومكن سهران في الشغل فلقيت حد
بيخبط على الباب الازاز فقمت بصيت ففتحته
فلقيته بيقول لي م
اختي فانا بقول له ايه قال لي م اختي فانا
بقول له مجدي قال لي اه ا قلت له اه ا هو
مش موجود بس في حد تاني انا عمال بتكلم ف
حسيته مش فاهمني وابتدى يقول حاجات انا مش
فاهمها فدخلت ندهت لحد من جوه قلت له سامي
في حد بره بيسال على مجدي انا مش عارف
مجدي ده كان زميلنا في الشركه يعني فالمهم
جاله ا شويه انا دهنه مجدي فمجد جه فلقيت
مجدي عمال يشاور له والولد عمال يتعصب
جامد قوي وكده فبيني وبينكم صعب عليا قوي
انه قلت ده حد من السم والبكم يعني
ف فضل يتناقش حبه كتيره وانا قاعد مراقبه
بعد ما خلصوا الحوار بينهم وبين بعض مشي
فانا بقول له مجدي هو ماله ده قال لي
الولد ده اسمه محمد وشغال في تشطيبات
السيراميك بتاعه محطات مترو الانفاق كنا
واخدين مقاولاتها يعني فقلت له ايه مشكلته
قال لي عنده مشكله ليه فلوس و المهندس
بتاع الموقع مش عايز يدي لله الفلوس دي
فقلت له يا اخي هو احنا هنبقى احنا والزمن
عليه المهم جريت ورا الولد طبعا انا مش
بعرف اتكلم لغه الاشارات فقلت له كتبت
رقمي تليفوني في ورقه وقلت له بص ده
تليفوني وده
اسمي لو عايز اي حاجه قعدت اعمل له كده
قلت له لو عايز اي حاجه كلمني يعني بعد 15
يوم لقيت تليفون جايلي حد بيقول لي انا من
طرف محمد اللي انت سبت له رقمك وهو عايز
يشوفك فرحت جدا بس وانا رايح ما بقتش فاهم
انا رايح اعمل ايه يعني واحد انا مش فاهم
لغته وهو مش فاهم لغتي طب هنتكلم مع بعض
نعمل ايه يعني فالمهم لما رحت معاه لقيته
بينطق بعض الالفاظ
ا ابتدى يحكي لي حكايته على قد ما يعني
على قد ما يقدر يوصل لي الفاظ هو مش سامع
طبعا خالص ان هو كان هو سن خمس سنين جات
له الحمه الشوكيه هي اللي افقدته السمع
بناء عليه ما بقاش يعرف يتكلم يعني
ا وقال لي بص يا امير انا انا يعني مبسوط
قوي ان انت اهتميت بيا و وانا هعلمك لغه
الاشاره خلي بالك احنا مش بنعلم لغه
الاشارات دي لحد لان احنا ما عندناش وشوشه
لو انت بتعرف لغه الاشارات اي اثنين
واقفين بيتكلموا في الشارع انت هتفهم
الحوار اللي بينهم ما ينفعش حد ياخد حد
على جنب كده ويوش وشوا زي ما انتوا
بتعملوا
اا ما كنتش فاهم ليه الموقف ده حصل في
حياتي بس انا مقتنع بحاجه لسه حتى كنت
بتناقش مع حد انه ما فيش حاجه بتحصل في
حياتنا صدفه وجودنا في في في المجتمع في
الدنيا في العالم اللي احنا فيه ده كله في
رساله ربنا حطتها جوه كل واحد فينا مش
الهدف ان انت تاكل وتشرب وتتجوز وتجيب
عيال وتخلف وخلاص لا انت ليك دور ولازم
تفضل طول حياتك تدور على دورك في كل مرحله
المفروض يبقى ايه الكلام ده كان في شهر
خمسه في شهر سبعه لقيت محمد جاي بيقول لي
طبعا كل الحوارات اللي هحكيها دي كلها ب
لغه الاشارات لقيته بيقول لي انا فرحان
قوي احنا طالعين العريش لمده اسبوع مع
مركز شباب عين السيره قلت لله طيب كويس
انا هجيلك الصبح عند مجمع التحرير في
القاهره هجيلك عشان اسلم عليك قبل ما تمشي
قاللي لا لا روح شغلك انت قلتله لا انا
هجيلك الصبح كان معاد الرحله الساعه 7
الصبح روحت لقيت 10 اتوبيسات مصر للسياحه
الرحله دي كانت تبع المجلس الاعلى للشباب
والرياضه تبع وزاره الشباب والرياضه
الكلام ده كان سنه 96
رحت وواخد معايا كيس بقى فيه سكتس وشيبسي
صاير وحاجات كده واديتهم له هو كان فرحان
جدا وهو كان يعني وشه بشوش قوي يعني فطلع
ركب الاتوبيس هو واصحابه وشويه جه مشرف
الرحله عايز ينده الاسماء ابتد ينده اسماء
الناس اللي موجوده في الباص بتاعه لغايه
ما جه عند اسماء
محمد وال 12 واحد زميله كانوا 13 واحد سم
وبكم قعد ينده الاسماء ما حدش يرد ينده
الاسماء ماحدش يرد فابتدع ورا فشاف قاعدين
في الاخر خالص عمالين بيشاوروا فندى على
واحد من المشرفين قال له لا ايه ده ايه ده
نزل لي ال 13 دول فانا كنت واقف جنبه مش
صدفه كنت واقف جنبه ا فجريت على الشباك
شاورت لمحمد قلت له ما تنزلش غير لما اقول
لك ورجعت تاني لل المشرف قلت له حضرتك
هينزلوا ليه قال لي حضرتك ده مؤتمر شباب
جمعي تثقيفي ودول 10 اتوبيسات طالعين
عندهم هياخدوا محاضرات وماعرفش ايه ا مش
هينفع يحضروا قلت له يا فندم معلش الكلام
الح بتقولوا مش مظبوط دول ناس اخدوا
اجازات من اشغالهم علشان يطلع يغير جو فما
ينفعش اجي دلوقتي اقول له انزل قال لي مين
حضرتك قلته انا لاقي واحد صاحبي
فيهم قاللي لا معلش ما هم مش هيطلعوا
قلتله هم مش هينزلوا فقال لي يعني ايه مش
هينزلوا قلتله يعني مش هينزلوا هو مش
هينزلوا غير اذا شاورتله ونزلته لو حضرتك
تعرف تنزلهم بالعافيه نزله فقال لي طيب
ممكن حضرك تتفضل معايا فوق في مجمع
التحرير في المكتب بتاع وزاره الشباب
قلتله ماشي الساعه بقى كانت دخلت في يه
طلعنا فوق عمل مكالمه تليفون فلقيت اللي
بيكلمني من الناحيه الانيه قاله بص حضرتك
هو معاك امير المترجم بتاعهم فاداني
التليفون فلقيت واحد صوته صاحي من النوم
فعلا يعني بيقوللي حضرتك مش هينفع يطلعوا
قمت رديت عليه بنفس الطريقه قلت له حضرتك
قاعد بتشرب القهوه وبتحل مشكله اساسا انت
مش شايفها ونت مغير لهجتي انا كنت خريج
بقي سنتين قلت له بص عموما حضرتك هو حقهم
هيجي
و وانا يعني انا اوعدك انه حق الشباب دول
مش هيتساب قاللي انت بتهددني قلت له انا
مش بهددك بس انا بوعدك ان حقهم هيجي نزلت
كانت الساعه دخلت في تعه يعني فضلت الع
10ش اتوبيسات متعطلين طول الساعتين دول
نزلت شاورت لمحمد قلت له انزل انت واصحابك
نزلوا مش قادر اوصف لكم علامات الحزن اللي
كانت على وشهم مش لان هم ما طلعوش الرحله
لا لانه هم حاسوا نفسهم
قليلين قلت له صدقني يا محمد يعني ربنا
يرتب حقكم هيجي رحت شغلي اليوم ده متاخر
ساعتين دخلت لمدير الحسابات قلت له انا مش
هشتغل لغايه ما اكتب حاجه لازم ابعتها
بريد الاهرام قال لي هتعمل ايه يعني لما
تبعت لبريد الاهرام قلت له هعمل اللي عل
مش هعمل حاجه اكتر من اللي عل قعدت كتبت
القصه اللي حصلت كلها وظبطها كويس قوي
وابتديت ابعتها فاكس على بريد الاهرام في
كان زمان بيجي في في جران الاهرام كده
حاجه اسمها بريد الاهرام بتبقى بيعرضوا
مشاكل من اللي بتحصل في البلد يعني فضلت
ابعت الفاكس ده وتطلع الورقه من الفاكس
وبعتها تاني وتطلع وابعتها تاني وتطلع
وابعتها تاني وبعته بالبريد يعني بعتته
بكل الطرق الكلام ده كان يوم 5/7 96 يوم
7/7 البريد 12 ا
في جرنان الاهرام
و واتعلق عليه انه فعلا السؤال اللي
بيساله امير تدرس عشان خاطر محمد صاحبه
وخلوا بالكم نتكلم بصراحه سنه 96 كانت من
السنين الشديده جدا في موضوع الفتنه
الطائفيه جوه مصر لان كان حصله حادثه في
الاقصر وبعدها حصلت حادثه قتل اقباط في
المنيا فانه يطلع في الوقت ده واحد اسمه
امير تدرس بيدافع عن حق محمد و1 شاب ما
فيهمش ولا و واحد مسيحي حتى عشان يتقال ان
امير بيعمل كده عشان واحد صاحبه فيهم يعني
12 البريد يوم
7/7 يوم 9/7 نزل اعتذار من وزاره الشباب
والرياضه لل 13 شاب ان الوزاره عملت فيهم
كده مع تعويض ان الوزاره هتطلع على حسابها
كنوع من انواع الاعتذار وطالبين انه امير
المترجم بتاعهم يروح يقابل وكيل وزاره
الشباب والرياضه علشان يتفق على المعسكر
اللي هم هيطلعو لما الكلام ده اشر في
الاهرام رحت للمدير بتاعي قلت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
له
ميرسي رحت المدير بتاعي ورميت له جرنان في
وشه قلت له انا عملت اللي عليا وربنا عمل
اللي عليه قلت له عن اذنك انا عندي معاد
مع وكيل وزاره الشباب والرياضه رحت على
هناك وانا لابس جينس وكوتشي ودقن طويله
دخلت على المكتب بتاعه سكرتيره بقول لها
عندي معاد مع محمد بيه قالت لي معلش عنده
اجتماع قلت لها طب لما يخلص قولي له امير
تدرس ما كملتش الكلمه قالت لي ثانيه واحده
دخلت خبطت عليه العادي بتاعنا يعني دخلت
خبطت عليه فالراجل فعلا كان عنده اجتماع
بس كتر خيره يعني اعتذر للناس وقال لي
اتفضل دخلت قعدت معاه لسه هيبدا يتناقش
معايا قال لي على فكره الاستاذ مصطفى مش
غلطان قلت له محمد وزمايله مش غلطانين قال
لي بس بس خلاص احنا جايبينك هنا عشان نحل
الموضوع مش عشان حاجه يعني فاتصل بواحد
اسمه الاستاذ صلاح انا فاكر الاسماء كويس
زي ما يكون الموقف حصل امبارح ا اتصل
بواحد اسمه استاذ صلاح قال لي ده مدير عام
معسكرات الشباب على مستوى جمهوريه مصر
العربيه انزل تحت افتح لك الخريطه بتاعه
مصر نقي المكان اللي انت عايز تاخدهم فيه
بس بشرط لازم تطلع معاهم قلت له انا موافق
اخدت اجازه من شغلي وطلعنا معسكر دولي في
بورسعيد قضيت اجمل خمس ايام في حياتي مع
13 شاب مسلم مافيش حد فيهم بينطق كلمه كنت
بتعامل مع 13 واحد كلهم او اغلبهم اكبر
مني انا اللي بوديهم البحر وانا اللي
باخدهم ننزل انزل بيهم المطار طاعم وانا
اللي بع بيهم في في المعسكر واحنا راجعين
وقف واحد منهم ابتدى يشاور انا بفهم 80%
من لغه الاشاره يعني اللي كان شغال بيها
فضل واقف قاعد عمال يقول احنا كنا طالعين
رحله والرحله دي اتلغت وبعد كده جينا
النهارده وانبسطنا وقضينا خمسه ايام وكده
كل ده بفضل مين وقم شاور عليا اوت اوف
الصمت اللي كنا فيه في الاتوبيس لان هو
بيشاور بس لقيت الاتوبيس كله بيسقف فانتم
متخيلين هم بيعملوا حاجه هم حتى مش سامعين
جست ان هم يدوا تقدير للي قدامهم ساعتها
ادركت انه احنا وجودنا مش صدفه مافيش حاجه
بتحصل في حياتنا صدفه كل واحد ليه دور
لازم يعرفه كويس دي حكايتي مع
محمد من هنا ابتديت افهم انه
ميرسي من هنا ابتديت افهم انه انه طالما
انا ادركت ان انا عل دور ناحيه كل حاجه
سلبيه ممكن اكون بشوفها في حياتي انه لازم
تبقى هي دي طريقه
تفكيري اتجوزت سنه 2002 سنه 2003 ربنا
رزقني بطفل اول اطفالي انا ولد وحيد
فبالنسبه لي اغسطينوس ده كان حكايه عمري
يعني ده ابني واخويا وكل حاجه عن سن سنتين
ونص اكتشفت ان عنده سمات توحد م عندوش
تواصل بصري عنده هايبر اكشن عنده تشتت تقل
التركيز فرط حركه متاخر في الكلام متاخر
في
النمو
وقالي لازم تعرض على طبيب
نفسي قلتلهم مش ققدر روح بابني الدكتور
واقوله لو سمحت عجلي
ابن افرجت على الفيلم
ده دي قصه هيلن كر اوكي انا عملت الكليب
ده مدته خمس دقائق هنشوف الحته دي واكمل
كلامي معاكم بعد
اذنكم
i know one word i can put the world in
hand won
take how do i tell you
that means a word and word
me
[موسيقى]
اسسس خلاص رجعت تاني القصر وابتدت تاكل
وتبهدل الدنيا زي ما هي عايزه في اللقطه
دي هي كانت المفروض انها عايزه تشرب
وبتطلب الميه بانها تحط ايديها في الميه
قالت لها لا انت لازم تجي تنطقي كلمه ميه
علشان
تشربي الكلمه الوحيده اللي كانت تعرفها
هيلن كيلر قبل ما تفقد السمع والكلام كلمه
وا هي كلمه وتر على قد ما عرفت تنطقها قبل
ما تجيلها
الحمه
[موسيقى]
ب
بتكتب لها حروف الكلمه زي ما علمتها لها
[موسيقى]
هي
كل حاجه هلمسها هتبدا تقوللها قوليلي ايه
دي فالمدرسه تكتبلها حروف الكلمه فهي
تعيدها عليها
[موسيقى]
تاني
star
[موسيقى]
في بدايه تعب ابني شفت الفيلم ده
ا الفيلم ده في منه فيرجن تاني بالالوان
فالبنت اللي قايمه بالبطله فيفيلم الالوان
تشبه ابني شويه
ف نفس الحركات اللي كانت هي بتعملها وهي
مش سامعه ومش شايفه كان ابني بيعمل حركات
شبيهه ليه من هز الراس وهز الايدين والجري
بسرعه وانه متاخر في الكلام وكده فقعدت
طول الفيلم ببكي بس طلعت من الفيلم ده
بالحاجه اللي مش صدفه انه اذا كانت
المدرسه اللي جايه
بالفلوس بالحب قدرت تخلي قدامها واحده مش
بتسمع ومش بتشوف ومش بتتكلم انها تنطق
اللي اللي يعرفوا قصه هيلن كيلر هيلن كيلر
خدت جايزه نوبل للسلام هيلن ليها محاضرات
بتقولها بالصوت موجود على اليوتيوب
بتقدروا تخشوا تسير شوا وتسمعوا عنها يعني
فقررت ان انا اعالج ابني جوه البيت
ا رجعت البيت بعد ما عرفت القصه بتاعته
كلها وانه ما عندوش تواصل بصري ما بيبص في
عينين اللي قدامه انه على طول قاعد على
الارض ما بيلعبش مع اصحابه كل الكلام
الشكاوي اللي كانت جايلي منه في الحضانه
وابتديت اقعده على رجلي في البيت وشه ل
وابتديت انا انا اللي ابص لعينيه ماستناش
هو يبص لي يعني هو يبص يمين اروح له انا
يمين يبص شمال اروح له شمال بعد حوالي
شهور كان ابتدى يلقط نن عيني كده لمده
ثانيه ثانيتين قلت خلاص يبقى في امل ا
نشكر ربنا بعد ثلاث اربع خمس ست شهور كان
موضوع التواصل البصري خاف كان موضوع انه
يجري هو ما كانش بيمشي كان على طول بيجري
على طراطيف صوابعه وكان عنده موضوع هز
الراس ده كنت بحط ايدي ورا راسه عشان مش
اعو علشان بس يحس ان انا انا اللي بتحكم
في هزه راسه فانا اللي اقول له لا سيب لي
راسك انا انا اللي هحرك مش انت عشان اخلي
الاوردر في ايدي انا لغايه ما وصل سنه
اربع سنين الكلام ده كان سن سنتين ونص لما
وصل سنه اربع سنين دخلنا عملنا المقابله
في المدرسه شبه اترفض لانه فضل يلف حوالين
مكتب المديره وجري قعد لوحده في في الاوضه
بتاعتها فقالت لي ابنك مش هيركز معانا في
المدرسه فقلت لها انا بترجاكي انك تقبليه
ولو حصل حاجه بعد كده كلموني وانا هاجي
اسحب الفايل بتاعه دخل المدرسه فعلا بعد
ثلاث اسابيع لقيت المدرسه بتكلمني بتقول
لي انا مش فاهمه انتوا بتتعاملوا مع ابن
حضرتك ده ازاي ابنك ما بيبصل ليش ابنك ما
بيطلعش حاجته من الشنطه ابنك على طول قاعد
لوحده ما بيكرر الكلام ورايا انا عندي 38
ولد في الفصل بعملهم بطريقه وابنك لوحده
بتعامل معاه بطريقه
ثانيه قلت لها طيب انا اس سذن حضرتك بس
اقفلي وانا خمس دقايق وهكلمك كنت سايق
العربيه في في القاهره كانت العربيه انهرت
طبعا من العياط لانه مطلوب مني ان انا
اروح احل الموضوع في المدرسه ابنك مش
متجاوب يعني اتفضل الفايل بتاعه في اللحظه
دي قعدت صليت في العربيه قلت له بص يا رب
الامير يقدر يعمله عمله المرحله اللي احنا
واقفين فيها دلوقتي دي دي لازم لازم انت
تمد ايدك انا مش هعرف اعمل فيها حاجه ندرت
ندر عندنا القديس اسمه ماري جرجس قلت له
بص احنا كنا في شهر 10 اغسطينوس عيد
ميلاده 311 ف قلت لله في كل عيد ميلاد
لاغسل انا هودي خروف في كنيسه من الكنايس
بتوعك يعني بس انا مش عايز الفايل بتاعه
يتسحب من
المدرسه كلمت المدرسه بعدها تاني في نفس
اليوم قلت لها هو انا لو عملت حفله عيد
ميلاد لاغسل في البيت حضرتك تشرفيني قالت
لي اه طبعا قلت لها بس انا عايز اوسينو
يشوفك وانت بتتكلمي وبتضحكي معايا في
البيت عندنا اعتقد ان ده نفسيا هيفرق معاه
في المدرسه قالتلي طب انا ما عنديش مشكله
خالص حفله عيد ميلاد اغسطينوس كانت يوم
الخميس يوم الجمعه الخرو في الدبح في
الشهر ده يوم السبت كنا متعودين ان احنا
بنقعد نذاكر انا وهو ست ساعات من 8 الصبح
لاثنين الظهر لانه كان عنده تاخر في
التحصيل الاطفال التوحيديين مش بيبقوا
قادرين يحصلوا بنفس الاطفال الطبيعيين
يعني اللي كنا بنخلص في ست ساعات الهومورك
خلصناه في اليوم ده في ساعتين الا ربع
حسيت ان انا يوميها خدت جائزه دكتوراه مع
ابني ان احنا قدرنا نعدي الوقت
ده الاسبوع ده كنا بنتعلم فيه نكتب حرف
الالف والبا الالف كانت سهله لان الالف
عصايه واقفه ال ب كان فيها مشكله ان ال ب
فيها سنه وشرطه طويله ونقطه محطوطه في
الاخر ففي نص ما انا بتكلم معاه وبزعق له
اكتب اكتب اكتب بكى اول ما بكى طبعا انا
ما استحملتش يعني فقلت له بص يا اغسطينوس
احنا مش هنذاكر شلت الكتب من قدام
الترابيزه وجبت ورقه اي ف رسمت عليها بطه
ولزقتها على الدولاب وجبت ورقه تانيه
وكتبت عليها حرف ب كبير وحطيتها تحتها قلت
له قاللي امال احنا هنعمل ايه يا قلت له
احنا هنرقص خدته شلته بقيت اجري اتنطط بيه
في الاوضه واجي عند الدولاب واقول له ايه
دي يا تينو يقول لي دي بط اقول له لا يا
حبيبي دي ب بت واخده واجري الف بيه تاني
ونرقص تاني ونجي عند الدولاب واقول له دي
ايه تينو يقوللي دي ب اقوله لا ب بت
الكلام ده كان يوم السبت يوم الاحد
اغسطينوس راح المدرسه رجع لقيته بيقول لي
بابا اقول لك به ايه تاني قلت له ايه
قاللي به
بابا ساعتها ادركت ان
انا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ساعتها ادركت ان انا يعني قمت بالدور اللي
عليا ناحيه ابني هو ده اللي عايز اقوله
النهارده انه كل واحد ليه دور كل واحد
ليه
رساله لو انت عايش بس علشان تاكل وتشرب
وتشتغل وتجيب فلوس وتصرفها اعرف ان انت
لسه ما لقتش دورك كل شاب لسه ما اتجوزش
وانت بتتجوز ما تدورش على زوجه دور على ام
لولادك وكل واحده لسه ماتجوزتش ما تدوريش
على زوج دوري على اب لاولادك ميرسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا